hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse it's good to be back it's
been a long time so sorry I started a
little bit later than scheduled I'm
having some issues with with the stream
so let me know if you can hear me if you
can see me the it it may be bad so I had
to force quit some applications right
now I have very little running on my
machine so today I'm gonna wait to hear
back and see if you can hear me and see
me before I go into this so let me know
all right well nobody's saying there's
something wrong usually that happens
quickly if something is wrong so I guess
I'll just start so really quick here's
why I haven't been streaming I got a new
job and before my old job I could live
stream while I was at work at my new job
I can't also I have a longer commute for
my new job so it's been tough to find a
time where I can I can actually stream
so the plan now is I think I could
consistently stream around 8 a.m.
Eastern Time on Wednesdays and Fridays
so I'm gonna try to do that and I'd like
to do a project with react native web
that's what I'm working with for my my
new job so I think it'll be better if I
if I stick with that that way I'll know
what's going on and the stream and the
project at work okay kind of like play
off of each other so
hey everybody there's a lot of people
saying hi Susan say hello
so this stream is gonna be kind of like
a short stream compared to some of my
older ones so I'm going to keep it maybe
like a half an hour maybe a little bit
longer and for this stream I'm just
going to set up a react native web
project so really quickly react native
so react is a JavaScript library that
helps you to build progressive web apps
react native is a JavaScript library
that allows you to create mobile apps
using react you can also create other
things so essentially you have this base
of of react that you can code and then
it can be turned into other applications
right that can run natively on different
devices so not just Android and iOS or
you know Windows machine but also you
could there there are other things for
like a VR application right or in this
case we're going to use react native and
have it run as a web site on the web it
looks like my image is frozen so right
now I guess as long as you can hear me
I'm okay with that
so why would we want to do this this
sounds crazy why not just use react well
the reason being you can write most of
your code and in react native with some
slight alterations depending on platform
and run it on many platforms so we build
for the web but at the same time we
could very easily turn that into an iOS
app an Android app
and whatever else you know comes out
that react native can kind of compile
into I guess so that's why I'm using
react native at work so that we could
very easily be cross-platform and that's
why I want to use it with this project
so let's get to some code and if my
image is frozen let's do this I'm gonna
get rid of the video for now okay so
that should help
I'll make maybe a little bit with like
frame rate and stuff or with the
freezing the video seems to be a little
bit more resource intensive so first
thing we're gonna do I am on a Mac so
this may be slightly different on
Windows but I want to open visuals
actually let's open first things first
let's open a Chrome window okay it
should be back now let me know how it is
now it looks like on my end it it looks
like it's better so hopefully it is a
bit better let me know I'm gonna you
know it's not the internet connection
for me it's it's my machine
so I just think that my MacBook Pros a
little bit old it doesn't have the the
specs to handle streaming like this so
I'll try to figure out something else
this may be a great excuse for me to get
a new computer so we'll see
okay so the resolution is probably lower
now so I'm gonna try to make the the
font as large as I possibly can and
let's try to alright yeah if if the if
the video is too bad then maybe check
out the recording this should be
available a little later
hopefully it'll be better but anyway
this is create react app you can check
this out more on your own if you'd like
but basically we're gonna do NP x create
react app and then we'll just name the
app so let me open up a terminal I use I
term later okay so I make this as big as
I can so you can see it alright so this
is just you know regular terminal I've
gone into my projects folder we're gonna
do create wrecked up and now let's name
it and for now let's say FCC react
actions do
let's do it like this it's gonna be a
weird name but for react native
especially when you're gonna try to do
this in your striction is coming to you
oh you can't contain capital letters
okay let's just call it it's gonna be
all together whoops what am i doing so
there's an issue when you try to use
this with mobile that you can't have
hyphens in your name so that's why I was
doing it all together like that all
right so this is gonna do its thing and
it's probably gonna take a little while
since we're streaming at the same time
so I'm gonna check out the live chat a
little bit okay so it looks like the
frame rates still really bad and that's
probably since I started doing this
okay
[Music]
yeah you know at this point if I put the
settings any lower I'll be streaming at
480 and that means the recording that'll
be available afterwards we'll still be
at 480 so I really don't want that it's
really hard to see the code so I may
just have to try streaming from a
different machine next time but
hopefully what I'm going to shoot
forward for this stream is let's just
try to get this installed so I can at
least show you the package.json file and
how we're gonna set that up and also if
anybody has any questions go ahead and
put it in the live chat right now and at
least I can answer some questions while
we're waiting I'm just gonna scroll down
through the chat a little bit to see if
anybody had asked anything
oh hey John Anson's here how's it going
okay okay Giuliano says it's working at
360 dpi I'd not ideal but that's working
yeah sorry for the really bad quality of
the stream this is way worse than it was
the last time I tried to stream on this
computer so I'm not sure what what
changed but it seems like something has
changed to make it even worse
so next time I stream I am definitely
going to change things up kid brave it's
definitely not you the video is freezing
a lot it's it's entirely my fault so Wow
this might take a little while hmm yeah
and this is making this take forever
okay so I'm probably not gonna make you
all suffer through that much more of
this is it actually done now
so this stream would just basically be
an introduction to the project then a
wonderful it did stop all right so now
that we've created this project using
create react app when actually go into
the project so we're gonna see the FCC
react native web now we're into the
project and now we can go we can open
that up in Visual Studio code which is
my code editor of choice and basically
we're gonna do almost everything from
there so we don't even need this
terminal anymore so I'm gonna go ahead
and shut that down and hopefully there's
your studio code will actually load up
so for those of you that joined maybe a
little bit later we're starting a brand
new project this is gonna be like a side
project for me so not what I what I've
done in the other streams there's no
longer responding just keep waiting a
little bit longer so I can't stream my
actual like work projects anymore my
full-time job but I'm gonna do the side
project and I'm gonna try to use the
same technology that I am using in my
project for my normal job let's see okay
so we're in here and this is our
package.json file you can see right away
it's very basic but it has it definitely
has what we need okay so what we need to
add in addition to this is we need to
add react react native I'm in react
native web after double check here maybe
you don't need really native yeah we may
just need react native web I'm actually
not gonna try to load this package here
Singh as it took forever to get this
working before so we'll add in react
native web and at that point we'll need
to add in some things so we need to add
this into this is we need add this in
our config ACLU's built-in support okay
you know what we don't need to add this
I had to use it on a project at work but
we should be alright basically react
native web works by like aliasing parts
of react so you could see like if we
were to do it manually
we do it with web pack also Babel but if
we use create react app this should work
right off the bat and basically allow us
to write react native code with create
react app which is very convenient so we
would add that in and then in addition
to our normal so basically instead of
our normal react script start we would
have a start for like react native web
and that would bring up a react native
code in a web browser and we'd be able
to work on it like a normal rat project
at the same time we could also use react
native to bring up the project as an ILS
up or an Android app like in a simulator
or in a connected device so for now for
the project we're just gonna stick with
the web version because it obviously my
ship my machine can't reason really
handle this but when you try to open up
a simulator like iOS simulator it takes
a lot of resources so even if I had a
really good computer it would still
probably mess up the stream so we're
just gonna stick with the web if you'd
like to do it for as an app we can go
over that but I can't really stream
stream that successfully unless I get a
really awesome computer so I think I'm
gonna start wrapping things up I'm gonna
answer a few questions that I see here
and then we're gonna wrap things up for
today I'll try to stream again
at the very least I'll try to stream
like Wednesday morning with a better
setup it's possible that I might be able
to do some weekend streams too if you
want to get notified about that
subscribe to this channel free code camp
channel turn on your notifications you
can follow me on twitter infosys below
you can follow me on instagram i notify
everyone on instagram and twitter when
I'm about to stream I have a lot of
pre-recorded videos if you want to see
those you can go to my youtube channel
the links in the description to this
video and I think we got a react
question so John Hansen says what's the
best place to use a switch statement as
a function inside render or in the
return the switch will load different
children components based on a state
change okay that's interesting
if I were doing it I don't know that
I've tried to use a switch statement
inside the render or not but it seems
like inside the render function would be
better for those of you who aren't
familiar with what we're talking about
this might help to show something if
it'll come up so like when we're talking
about the the render function I'm sorry
the return so if it allows it which I'm
not sure if if it would allow it or not
to put a switch statement in the return
I've never tried it it would make sense
to put it in the return and just have
different things come up you usually I
just use turn Ares inside the return and
that that usually works but it could get
complicated if you had a lot of options
let's see yeah John if you end up trying
that and it works let me know I'd really
like to see that because I've never
attempted it before what I have done
before is used a ternary like out here
and the ternary would change the state
right then depending on the value of
state it would render things in here so
there would be something like for this
component it would say something like I
don't know route this is call it route
we would say right this state this state
route and then I would say like equals
and let's just say home ok let's say we
have a string of home and now we're
gonna say
[Music]
and and then we'd put a component here
and then what that would do is say okay
if the route equals home we're gonna
render this home component and then
you'd wrap each component in something
like this but the value of this state
route would be different for each one
then you have your switch statement up
here that changes state so that would
essentially achieve the same thing you
would add a bit more code but then you
wouldn't put a switch statement in the
return which I know this works I'm not
sure if a switch statement works that
makes sense as anybody else tried to
work with switch statements in in the
return all right name are asked which
this four we're working with react
native it's just a live stream to show
like what is the process is like to code
without rehearsing and there's there's a
lot of mistakes that happen and like we
we just go through them together we have
a question about suggesting a good es
six through eight course